Willkommen zurück bei Quantencomputing in der Praxis. In dieser Episode geht es um den ersten und oft auch schwierigsten
Schritt bei der Definition eines Quantenprogramms: die Abbildung eines allgemeinen Problems auf einen circuit, der auf einem Quantencomputer
ausgeführt werden kann. Dieser Schritt beschreibt, wie ein Nutzer, der mit einem bestimmten Rechenproblem beginnt,
es so übersetzen kann, dass ein Quantencomputer es versteht.
In früheren Lektionen dieser Reihe, Lektion zwei und drei, haben wir besprochen, dass die Mapping-Phase der erste von
vier Schritten im Qiskit-Patterns-Framework ist. Aus diesen Lektionen erinnerst du dich vielleicht daran, dass unser Ziel war, ein
Rechenproblem in eine Kostenfunktion oder einen Erwartungswert umzuschreiben,
den wir mithilfe eines Quantencomputers auswerten können.
In Lektion drei haben wir ein konkretes Beispiel mit Max Cut besprochen, einem Problem,
das rechnerisch anspruchsvoll und in der kombinatorischen Optimierung weit verbreitet ist.
In diesem Beispiel haben wir mehrere Schritte durchlaufen, um den ursprünglichen Graphen in ein quantennatives Problem zu überführen.
Wir haben das Problem, die maximale Anzahl von Schnitten im Graphen zu finden, in eine Kostenfunktion umgewandelt, diese dann
als Hamiltonoperator neu formuliert und einen Trial-Quantenzustand vorbereitet, dessen Grundzustand
dem Max Cut entspricht. Schließlich haben wir einen Quanten-circuit konstruiert, der den gewünschten Trial-Quantenzustand darstellt,
und dann spezifische gates hinzugefügt, damit der Zustand sich über die Zeit entwickeln kann. Diese Abfolge von Schritten nennen wir
Mapping. Und auf einer übergeordneten Ebene ist das Verfahren allgemein auf viele andere Anwendungen übertragbar, wie etwa Quantenchemie
und Quantensimulation. Nun lässt sich nicht leugnen, dass Mapping schwierig sein kann. Es gibt keine
Einheitslösung für jedes einzelne Problem, was einschüchternd wirken kann. Heute werde ich
einige repräsentative Beispiele verschiedener Probleme vorstellen und beschreiben, wie sie jeweils abgebildet wurden. Ich werde kurz
zusammenfassen, was wir über Graphenprobleme wie die bei Max Cut gelernten haben, und den Rest der Vorlesung damit verbringen,
zu erklären, wie man Probleme abbildet, die in der Natur vorkommen, etwa Probleme der Molekülstruktur in der Biologie, der
elektronischen Struktur in der Chemie und die Simulation von Quantenfeldtheorien in der Hochenergiephysik.
Aber bevor wir in dieser Episode die meiste Zeit damit verbringen, Beispielprobleme aus der Literatur zu betrachten, möchte ich dir
einen Überblick über die wichtigsten Dinge geben, die wir beim Mapping eines Problems anstreben und berücksichtigen wollen. Es gibt
einige Aspekte, die bei jeder Art von Rechenproblem zu bedenken sind, das in einen Quanten-circuit übersetzt werden muss.
Erstens musst du das Problem möglicherweise vereinfachen, um es handhabbar zu machen. Das ist in den meisten wissenschaftlichen
Disziplinen üblich und nicht einzigartig für das Quantencomputing. Falls du jemals den Ausdruck „Nimm eine
sphärische Kuh an" gehört hast, spielt er darauf an, dass es oft schwer ist, ein System genau so zu beschreiben, wie es erscheint. Stattdessen
können wir vernünftige Vereinfachungen vornehmen, die dennoch zu nützlichen Lösungen führen können.
Einige Beispiele, wie wir das im Quantencomputing umsetzen könnten, sind die Begrenzung der Größe oder der circuit-Tiefe durch die Wahl
hardwareeffizienter Ansätze, das Abschneiden komplexer Zeitentwicklungen oder das Vernachlässigen von
Hamiltonoperator-Termen, die wenig zur Gesamtenergie eines Quantenzustands beitragen.
Der nächste Punkt, den ich ansprechen möchte, ist, dass du das Problem so formulieren musst, dass ein Quantencomputer damit umgehen kann.
Das beinhaltet häufig die folgenden drei Fragen. Erstens: Was sollen unsere qubits
in diesem Modell darstellen? Zweitens: Ist unser Problem kontinuierlich? Da Quantencomputer digital arbeiten, musst du
einen Weg finden, das Problem zu diskretisieren. Und drittens: Stimmt die Topologie des Problems mit der Topologie der
Hardware überein? Wenn ja, ist das prima. Wenn nicht, müssen wir möglicherweise einige Tricks anwenden, damit es funktioniert. Gehen wir also auf
diese erste Frage ein. Was ich für den Kern aller Schwierigkeiten beim Verständnis von Mapping halte, besonders als
neues Konzept: Was kann ein qubit darstellen?
Qubits können viele Dinge darstellen. Das Erste und meiner Meinung nach Einfachste ist ein Knoten in einem Graphen. Graphen werden
verwendet, um Konnektivität in vielen verschiedenen Arten von mathematischen Problemen darzustellen. Die Knoten sind ein grundlegendes Element und repräsentieren einen Punkt
oder eine Einheit innerhalb eines Netzwerks. Je nachdem, was das gesamte Netzwerk darstellt, kann das eine Stadt, eine Person oder ein
Ferromagnet in einem Gitter sein. Qubits können auch zur Darstellung von Bosonen und Fermionen verwendet werden. Ich möchte hier jedoch darauf hinweisen,
dass ein einzelnes qubit nicht genau einem Boson oder einem Fermion entspricht. Es ist ein
bisschen kniffliger als das, und ich werde gleich darauf eingehen, aber generell ist eine Spinkette, die einer bestimmten Statistik folgt,
etwas, das sich leicht in eine qubit-Architektur übersetzen lässt.
Jetzt kommen wir zu etwas komplizierteren Beispielen. Bei diesen Modellen ergibt es keinen Sinn mehr,
von einem einzelnen qubit zu sprechen.
Stattdessen brauchen wir Gruppen von ihnen, um etwas Physikalisches darzustellen. Zum Beispiel kann eine
Gruppe von qubits, hier auf einer Heavy-Hexagonal-Topologie dargestellt, verwendet werden, um geometrische Positionen von Aminosäuren
oder Polymerketten darzustellen. Ein weiteres Beispiel ist die Simulation von Hadronenstreuung
in Hochenergiephysikmodellen, die durch Simulation der Zeitentwicklung eines hadronischen Wellenpakets erfolgen kann. In diesem Fall
kann ein Register aus qubits verwendet werden, um verschiedene Zustände eines Quantenfeldes zu kodieren: den Vakuumzustand dieses Feldes oder
ein Wellenpaket, das sich über diesem Vakuum ausbreitet.
Ich möchte außerdem darauf hinweisen, dass die Abbildung des Problems auf einen Quantencomputer unterschiedliche Schritte umfasst, nämlich erstens die Abbildung der
Zustände auf qubits und circuits und zweitens die Abbildung der Kostenfunktion oder des Erwartungswerts
der quantenmechanischen Observablen und Operatoren. Wir werden sehen, wie diese in konkreten Beispielen behandelt werden. Aber
bis jetzt haben wir abstrakt genug über die Herausforderung gesprochen, die vor uns liegt.
Schauen wir uns diese Beispiele jetzt im Detail an.
Beginnen wir mit unserem ersten Beispiel. Meiner Meinung nach ist eines der einfachsten Mapping-Probleme das, das wir bereits
das Max-Cut-Beispiel ausführlich behandelt. Bei diesem Problem war das Mapping für uns ganz einfach, weil ein qubit
einem Knoten in unserem Graphen entspricht. Die Verwendung von Knoten in einem Graphen ist sehr intuitiv, und das ist
praktisch, weil es vielen Anwendungen entspricht. Wenn du etwas modellieren möchtest, das
einer Reihe von miteinander verbundenen Knoten entspricht, und die Gruppierungen binär sind – also null oder eins, oder enthalten und nicht enthalten in einer
Menge –, kannst du diese Knoten einfach und natürlich auf Bits oder qubits abbilden.
In diesem Beispiel, und sogar in dem, das wir in Episode 3 auf 100 qubits skaliert haben, passte die Graph-Konnektivität
bereits zur Topologie unserer supraleitenden Hardware. Wir mussten uns also auch damit nicht beschäftigen. Das ist aber nicht immer der Fall.
Und wenn du einen komplizierteren oder stärker verbundenen Graphen hast als die Beispiele, die wir bisher gezeigt haben, wirst du
Swap-gates implementieren müssen. Das wird aber tatsächlich im zweiten Schritt der Qiskit-Patterns behandelt, der sich mit
dem transpiler beschäftigt. Der andere Aspekt des Max-Cut-Problems, der es so praktisch macht, ist, dass wir
bereits wissen, wie man die Kostenfunktion als Hamiltonian mit der QUBO-Formulierung ausdrückt.
Zur Erinnerung: In der Quantencomputation und bei variationellen Quantenalgorithmen ist eine Hamiltonian-Kostenfunktion eine Funktion,
die die optimale Lösung des Problems im Grundzustand des Hamiltonians kodiert.
Um den Kosten-Hamiltonian zu konstruieren, konnten wir die Sparse-Pauli-Op-Klasse in Qiskit verwenden, um die
Konnektivität unseres Graphen zu spezifizieren, und die Abbildung auf die Quantenoperatoren im Mapping-Schritt ist erledigt. Und der quantum circuit war
einfach der QAOA-Ansatz. Wenn dir das nichts sagt, schau dir bitte Episode 3 an, wo wir das
viel ausführlicher durchgehen. Jetzt wollen wir den Schwierigkeitsgrad ein kleines bisschen erhöhen. Als nächstes werden wir uns
ein Beispiel anschauen, das in dem Paper modelliert wurde mit dem Titel „Resource Efficient Quantum Algorithm for Protein Folding", geschrieben von
IBM in Zusammenarbeit mit der University of New South Wales. Ein bisschen Biochemie-Hintergrund: Proteine sind
Makromoleküle, die aus langen Ketten von Aminosäuren bestehen. Diese langen Ketten falten sich
in komplexe Strukturen, die eine Vielzahl biologischer Funktionen erfüllen.
Die Bestimmung einer Proteinstruktur im dreidimensionalen Raum und das Verständnis der Beziehungen zwischen
Struktur und Funktion gehören heute zu den größten Herausforderungen in der Biochemie.
Proteine falten sich aufgrund von Wechselwirkungen zwischen den Aminosäuren selbst in nützliche Strukturen.
Wenn sich die Struktur dreht und faltet, können Aminosäuren, die in der Kette weit voneinander entfernt sind, direkt nebeneinander
enden und stark miteinander wechselwirken. Wir benötigen einen Hamiltonian, der all diese Wechselwirkungen zwischen den Amino-
säuren beschreibt, wenn wir vorhersagen wollen, welche endgültige Struktur die Energie minimiert. Hier konzentrieren wir uns auf Aminosäureketten und
wie sie auf einem Quantencomputer modelliert werden können, und dann wie wir Abstände zwischen den Aminosäuren ermitteln können, um
die Wechselwirkungsenergien zu berechnen.
Damit haben wir tatsächlich alle notwendigen Beiträge zum Hamiltonian gesammelt, um ihn zu simulieren
auf einem Quantencomputer. Bei realen Proteinen können Aminosäuren ein Kontinuum möglicher Positionen einnehmen.
Wir werden hier jedoch eine Vereinfachung verwenden und sie auf ein Gittermodell beschränken, bei dem jede Aminosäure
einen Punkt auf einem Gitter einnimmt. Hier verwendeten die Autoren ein tetraedrisches Gitter.
Kurzer Hinweis: Hier kodieren wir die Richtung der Kanten und nicht die Knoten selbst wie beim Max-Cut-Problem.
Jedes qubit repräsentiert einen möglichen Einzelschritt-Pfad entlang des tetraedrischen Gitters. Beachte, dass die benachbarten Gitterpunkte
in diesem Diagramm als A oder B bezeichnet wurden, wegen ihrer unterschiedlichen Orientierungen im Gitter.
Die Proteinkette wird als eine Reihe von Drehungen oder Richtungen auf diesem
Gitter dargestellt. Jede Drehung zwischen den Aminosäuren kann in eine von vier Richtungen gehen,
die den Kanten des Tetraeders entsprechen.
Diese vier möglichen Drehungen werden mit vier qubits kodiert.
Das klingt etwas kompliziert. Schauen wir uns dieses Beispiel also etwas genauer an.
Lass uns unsere erste Aminosäure auf diesem Punkt im tetraedrischen Gitter platzieren. Die Richtung zur ersten
Aminosäure zur zweiten ist beliebig, weil das System immer so gedreht werden kann, dass diese Kante in
eine beliebige Richtung zeigt. Lass uns also unsere zweite Aminosäure hier platzieren. Es ist nicht so
einfach zu erkennen, aber der Weg von der zweiten zur dritten ist ebenfalls beliebig. Alle drei Entscheidungen würden
dazu führen, dass zwei der Kanten einen Winkel von ungefähr 109,5°
zwischen sich haben. Die Wahl dieser zweiten Kante bestimmt lediglich die Orientierung unseres Proteins im Raum. Ohne Beschränkung der
Allgemeinheit können wir also wählen, dass die ersten Drehungen einfach 0 0 1 und 0 0 1
0 sind. Mit diesen Vereinfachungen wird die Konfiguration der Aminosäurekette einfach durch diesen Ausdruck beschrieben.
Bisher haben wir die Tetraederkanten auf qubits abgebildet, und unser quantum circuit wird ein Ansatz sein. Jetzt müssen wir
überlegen, wie wir die Energie des Problems in einen Hamiltonian kodieren, sodass sein Grundzustand uns das optimale
Faltungsmuster liefert. Für eine gegebene Konfiguration gibt es eine zugehörige Energie aufgrund der
Wechselwirkungen zwischen den Aminosäuren selbst. Diese Wechselwirkungen sind am stärksten, wenn die beiden Aminosäuren
nahe beieinander sind. Natürlich werden Aminosäuren, die im Rückgrat der Kette benachbart sind, immer miteinander wechselwirken.
Aber weil das Protein sich drehen und falten kann, können auch andere Aminosäure-Paare
miteinander wechselwirken. Aminosäuren 10 und 20 können zum Beispiel nach der Faltung des Proteins
auf benachbarten Gitterplätzen landen. Aminosäuren, die nahe beieinander enden, haben stärkere
Wechselwirkungen und treiben den Faltungsprozess an, aber sie haben nicht unbedingt Indizes, die nahe beieinander liegen.
Wir brauchen also eine Formel, um den Abstand D zwischen den Aminosäuren I und
J mithilfe der auf den Konfigurations-qubits kodierten Informationen zu beschreiben. Damit können wir
ihren Abstand verwenden, um zu bestimmen, wie stark sie miteinander wechselwirken. Das ist etwas kompliziert
aber hab Geduld mit mir, denn es ist ein cleverer Trick. Zuerst führen wir eine Funktion f sub a von i ein, die angibt, ob
eine Kante a für die Biegung an der Aminosäure i verwendet wird oder nicht. Hier kann a jeden
der vier möglichen Richtungen annehmen, ausgehend von der obigen Konfigurationskodierung. Wir können diese Funktionen aufschreiben und dann
eine Differenz in der Anzahl der mit a bezeichneten Biegungen auf den A- und B-Gittern definieren
vom Index I bis zum Index J als delta N. Warum würden wir das tun? Es stellt sich heraus, dass das
Tetraedergitter eine sehr nützliche Eigenschaft hat. Schauen wir uns diese Aminosäure hier genauer an. Es spielt keine Rolle, welche
es ist, aber nennen wir sie die E-Aminosäure. Wir wollen wissen, wie weit die j-Aminosäure entfernt sein wird. Und alles, was wir haben,
sind die Kanten, entlang derer das Rückgrat schreitet. Ausgehend von I ist festzustellen, dass ein Schritt
vom Zentrum entlang eines bestimmten Kantentyps – nenn ihn a – von diesem A-Gitter
Punkt genau entgegengesetzt ist und durch einen Schritt entlang der Kante a vom
B-Punkt rückgängig gemacht wird. Mehrere Schritte entlang Kante A von einem A-Gitterpunkt bewegen das
Rückgrat von der E-Aminosäure weg, und Schritte entlang Kantentyp A von B-Punkten
bringen dich zurück. Der Abstand zwischen zwei Aminosäuren I und J entlang des Kanten-
typs, den wir A nennen, hängt von der Differenz zwischen den Schritten entlang A
von A-Punkten und B-Punkten ab. Da A und B im Protein-
rückgrat zwangsläufig abwechseln, wird dies durch den Term minus 1 hoch K erfasst. Dieses Argument gilt auch für andere Kantentypen,
also kann der Abstand zwischen Aminosäuren in den Tetraedergitter-Schritten am Ende durch diesen
Ausdruck berechnet werden. Aber wie leiten wir den Hamiltonian aus dieser langen Gleichung für den Gesamtabstand zwischen den Aminosäuren ab? Es
gibt tatsächlich eine Eins-zu-eins-Entsprechung zwischen diesen Abständen in den Tetraedergitter-Schritten und dem
euklidischen Abstand. Und du kannst sehen, dass ich einige der Ausdrücke bereits für dich berechnet habe.
Diese Abstände können zur Berechnung der Energie deiner Konfiguration verwendet werden.
Je nach deinem Zweck kannst du einen Abstandsschwellenwert festlegen, unterhalb dessen du das Paar als wechselwirkend betrachtest,
oder du machst etwas Komplizierteres. Es ist vielleicht nicht offensichtlich, aber wir sind tatsächlich mit der Abbildungs-
phase fertig, indem wir das getan haben. Die Zustände der qubits zeigen die Biegung an, und die Gesamtheit der Biegungen bestimmt den
Abstand zwischen jedem Paar von Aminosäuren. Paare verschiedener Arten von Amino-
säuren haben unterschiedliche Wechselwirkungen, manche anziehend, manche abstoßend. Wenn du die Konfiguration und den Abstand verwendest, um
lediglich festzustellen, ob bekannte Aminosäure-Wechselwirkungen an oder aus sind,
sind deren Stärken bekannt. Nicht von mir, aber du kannst sie in einer Tabelle wie dieser hier nachschlagen. Zusammenfassend gilt in
diesem Beispiel: Die qubits werden verwendet, um Positionen auf einem Gitter zu markieren, die zusammen eine Kette von Aminosäuren bilden.
Indem wir simulieren, wie sie sich biegen und falten, können wir hoffentlich bessere Ergebnisse in der medizinischen Forschung erzielen. Wir haben
übersprungen, wie einige Terme dieses Hamiltonians zu berechnen sind, da sie sehr spezifisch für dieses Problem waren. Die Definition von
Richtungen auf einem Gitter kann jedoch allgemeiner angewendet werden.
Sobald du einen allgemeinen Hamiltonian hast, wirst du ihn immer in Pauli-Operatoren übersetzen wollen,
die dem Quantencomputer eigen sind. Das werden wir als Nächstes besprechen.
Weiter geht's. Lass uns nun erkunden, wie man ein System subatomarer Teilchen in Pauli-Operatoren übersetzen kann. Subatomare
Teilchen werden in zwei Kategorien unterteilt: Bosonen und Fermionen. Bosonen
wie Photonen oder das Higgs-Boson gehorchen einem bestimmten Satz statistischer Regeln, und Fermionen wie Elektronen oder Neutrinos gehorchen einem anderen.
Der wesentliche Unterschied zwischen ihnen besteht darin, dass Bosonen den gleichen Zustand besetzen dürfen. Es gibt keine Begrenzung, wie viele
Bosonen sich im Grundzustand oder einem anderen angeregten Zustand befinden können. Fermionen hingegen sind egoistisch. Sie verlangen, dass
jedes einzelne Teilchen seinen eigenen Quantenzustand hat. Bosonen haben außerdem ganzzahligen Spin, während Fermionen halbzahligen
Spin haben, wie das Spin-1/2-Elektron oder exotischere Spin-3/2-Teilchen. Um
ein System von Teilchen zu beschreiben, brauchen wir eine Beschreibung ihrer Energie. Konzentrieren wir uns auf Fermionen. Wir können mit dem
Hamiltonian beginnen, der in Bezug auf das geschrieben ist, was wir C-Operatoren nennen. Das sind im Grunde mathematische Objekte, die
dem Erzeugen oder Vernichten eines Fermions aus einem Zustand im System entsprechen.
Diese werden oft als fi dagger und fi in einer Notation geschrieben, die wir zweite
Quantisierung nennen. Nun ist fi dagger der Operator, der ein Fermion im Zustand i erzeugt. Fi ist
der Operator, der ein Fermion im Zustand i vernichtet. Aber denk daran: Quantencomputer arbeiten normalerweise in einer qubit-
Basis mit spezifischen Regeln zur Darstellung fermionischer Systeme. Sie arbeiten nicht von Natur aus in der Sprache der
fermionischen Operatoren. Um diese Lücke zu schließen, müssen wir die zweite Quantisierung in Pauli-Operatoren abbilden,
die auf natürliche Weise quantum gates entsprechen.
Es gibt mehrere solcher Transformationen für Fermionen. Eine gängige Wahl ist die Jordan-Wigner-Transformation.
Die Bravyi-Kitaev- und Paritäts-Abbildungen sind neuere Kodierungen für fermionische Systeme.
Bosonische Operationen hingegen können durch die Holstein-Primakoff-Transformation transformiert oder direkt
durch Abbildung der Fock-Zustände auf eine Teilbasis der verfügbaren bosonischen Moden umgewandelt werden.
Und es gibt auch andere Optionen für Bosonen. Weitere Kodierungen werden ebenfalls aktiv erforscht. Aber für jetzt
konzentrieren wir uns nur auf die Jordan-Wigner-Transformation.
Warum weisen wir also nicht einfach jedem Elektron ein qubit zu? Nun, das können wir nicht.
Qubits sind unterscheidbar und Elektronen sind es nicht. Zum Beispiel können wir einzelne qubits auf einem
Gerät leicht beschriften und identifizieren, aber die Ununterscheidbarkeit von Elektronen bedeutet, dass wir sie überhaupt nicht beschriften können. Wir müssen stattdessen tatsächlich
die Operatoren entsprechend besetzter Orbitale beschriften, wie 1s, 2s und 2p,
anstatt spezifischer Elektronen. Daher müssen wir die Operatoren tatsächlich entsprechend besetzter Orbitale beschriften, wie 1s
2s und 2p, anstatt bestimmte Elektronen zu benennen. Jedes qubit spielt also
ungefähr die Rolle eines Orbitals im Molekül, das entweder besetzt oder unbesetzt ist.
Aber wie wir das machen, ist tatsächlich etwas komplizierter. Jetzt führen wir etwas ein, das sich Jordan-Wigner-Mapping nennt, um
die Antisymmetrie zu berücksichtigen und sicherzustellen, dass die korrekten Statistiken des gesamten fermionischen Systems eingehalten werden. Das Jordan-
Wigner-Mapping ist konzeptionell einfach, weil es eine Eins-zu-Eins-Korrelation zwischen den Orbitalen und qubits gibt. Es
gibt andere Mappings, die ein ähnliches Ziel erreichen, einschließlich des Parity-Mappings.
Die Berechnung der Parität eines Zustands erfordert die Berücksichtigung mehrerer qubits. Beim Parity-Mapping und einigen anderen gilt die
Interpretation, dass ein qubit einem Orbital entspricht, nicht mehr.
Lass uns jetzt gemeinsam ein ziemlich einfaches Beispiel durchgehen, um sicherzustellen, dass wir diese Transformation verstanden haben.
Angenommen, wir möchten die Einzelqubit-Wechselwirkung f dagger f berechnen. Wir beginnen damit, unsere Definitionen für die
Aufsteige- und Absteigeoperatoren einzusetzen. Dann können wir Terme gruppieren und die Identitätsmatrix i sowie den Faktor 1/4 ausklammern.
Wie wir sehen, bleiben uns Terme, die denjenigen vertraut sein werden, die sich mit Kommutatorrelationen beschäftigen. Dieser Term hier in
der Klammer ist nichts anderes als i mal dem Kommutator von x und y. Und vergiss
nicht die Identität, die wir herausgezogen haben.
Denk daran, dass das nur Pauli-Matrizen sind. Daher ist der Kommutator wohlbekannt. Der Kommutator von x und y in
dieser Reihenfolge ist einfach. Es ist 2 i z. Pass auf, dass du deine Vorzeichen nicht verlierst, und du erhältst dies als dein abschließendes
Ergebnis. Am Ende haben wir erfolgreich einen fermionischen Ausdruck umgeschrieben in
Terme von Pauli-Operatoren, die unser Quantencomputer verstehen kann.
Lass uns kurz besprechen, wie wir das Jordan-Wigner-Mapping in Qiskit implementieren würden, denn obwohl ich denke, dass es
wichtig ist zu verstehen, wie das Mapping und ähnliche Transformationen funktionieren, und es mindestens einmal durchgearbeitet zu sehen,
würdest du das nicht jedes Mal manuell durchrechnen wollen.
Besonders bei großen Systemen können wir die Sparse-Pauli-Op-Funktion in Qiskit nutzen, um
die zugehörigen Pauli-Operationen aus einem Mapping einfach zu erstellen. Eine nicht-optimale
Implementierung nutzt verschachtelte Schleifen und benötigt etwa 20 Codezeilen.
Ich werde den Code hier verlinken, damit ihr ihn erkunden könnt. Auf hoher Ebene sind die Schritte wie folgt.
Erstens: Verwende die Sparse-Pauli-Ops-from-list-Funktion, um einen Identitätsoperator zu erstellen,
der der Größe des zu mappenden Parameterraums entspricht. Zweitens: Verwende entsprechend der Definition der Erzeugungs-
und Vernichtungsoperatoren, die zuvor gezeigt wurden, die Sparse-Pauli-Ops-from-list-Funktion, um die x-, y- und z-Pauli-
Operationen zu definieren. Damit werden die fermionischen Erzeugungs- und Vernichtungsoperatoren auf qubit-Spin-Operatoren abgebildet, die die fermionische
Besetzungszahl in die Rechenbasis der qubits kodieren, und drittens: Erzeuge den gewünschten
Hamiltonoperator in der Pauli-Basis, indem du die obigen Operatoren auf die Orbitale von Interesse anwendest. Das entspricht üblicherweise der
Erstellung einer Identitätsmatrix, die den Kern – die nicht-wechselwirkenden Orbitale – repräsentiert, und dann dem Anwenden der Erzeugungs-
und Vernichtungsoperatoren auf den aktiven Raum mit Gewichten, die den spezifischen Eigenschaften des vorliegenden Problems entsprechen. Wie
ich erwähnt habe, ist das nur eine übergeordnete Übersicht. Der Code ist aber nicht allzu kompliziert, und du solltest jetzt
sicher sein, ihn für andere interessante Probleme anzupassen.
Nun, da wir das Jordan-Wigner-Mapping-Schema vollständig verstehen, sehen wir es in Aktion in einem komplizierteren Aufbau. Du
erinnerst dich vielleicht an dieses Paper aus einer früheren Episode über Hadron-Dynamik. Ich werde das Paper nicht nochmal ausführlich besprechen, aber schau dir bitte
die vorherige Episode an, wenn du sie verpasst hast und neugierig bist. In diesem Beispiel wird das Jordan-Wigner-Mapping verwendet, um
den Hamiltonoperator von Gitterplätzen mit L Stellen für das Schwinger-Modell in Abwesenheit eines elektrischen Feldes auszudrücken. Hier
ist es viel schwieriger, genau zu bestimmen, was ein qubit in diesem Modell repräsentiert, da es nur die
Gesamtheit der qubits zusammen ist, die etwas Physikalisches ausmacht. In diesem Kontext: ein Wellenpaket. Stattdessen kannst du dir die
qubits grob als diskretisierte Raumstücke vorstellen, wobei L hier das Gittervolumen ist, in dem jedes Element bzw.
jede Einheitszelle aus zwei qubits besteht. Die fermionischen Operatoren, die wir auf der vorherigen Folie gesehen haben, beschreiben die Amplitude der
Wellenfunktion an einem bestimmten Gitterplatz.
Unser Hamiltonoperator enthält also diese fermionischen Aufsteige- und Absteigeoperatoren. Aber um einen solchen
Hamiltonoperator auf einem Quantencomputer zu implementieren, müssen wir ihn in Spin-Operatoren ausdrücken, nicht in fermionischen Operatoren.
Deshalb verwenden wir die Jordan-Wigner-Transformation. Nach Anwendung der Jordan-Wigner-Transformation wird unser neuer
Hamiltonoperator zu dieser Gleichung am unteren Rand der Folie, wobei Sigma-plus der Pauli-Operator X + I Y ist und Sigma-
minus X - IY ist. Sobald wir einen Hamiltonoperator in diesem Format haben, ist der
schwierige Teil der Mapping-Phase vorbei, und er kann nun leicht in einem circuit in Pauli-Operatoren geschrieben werden.
Zusammenfassend haben wir vier Beispiele besprochen, wie spezifische Mapping-Techniken in letzter Zeit im
Quantencomputing-Bereich eingesetzt wurden. Beginnend mit dem einfachsten und uns vorarbeitend bis zur Anwendung der Jordan-Wigner-Transformation auf
Hadron-Dynamik. Ich bin mir bewusst, dass das eine Menge ist. Dieses Material war sehr technisch,
und wenn du es noch nicht gesehen hast, kann es sehr einschüchternd sein. Die gute Nachricht ist, dass ich verspreche, es wird einfacher und
vertrauter, je mehr Zeit du mit Üben verbringst. Und das ist wirklich der Kern der Sache und der Grund, warum ich die gesamte
Serie „Quantum Computing in Practice" genannt habe.
Das ist nichts, das jemand einfach aufgreifen und von Anfang an damit loslegen kann. Es erfordert etwas Lernen,
etwas Grübeln und wahrscheinlich einige frustrierende Momente. Aber ich ermutige euch alle, mit dem Unbehagen zu sitzen und
die Fragen wirklich zu erforschen, die auftauchen, während du weitermachst, denn das ist der einzige Weg, wirklich zu lernen. Danke fürs
Zuschauen. Das war Episode 5 von Quantum Computing in Practice. Beim nächsten Mal werden wir erkunden, wie man einen
Hamiltonoperator von Grund auf simuliert. Wir sehen uns bald.